in
[Music]
[Applause]
I would like to welcome to the stage our
speaker Dr Zakir Nike speaking on the
subject the Quran and modern science
compatible or incompatible I would like
to give you now a brief introduction of
Dr Zakir Nike and truly it is a brief
introduction because there is too much
to be said he is a medical doctor by
professional training and a renowned
Dynamic International orator on Islam
and comparative
religion he is the president of the
Islamic Research Foundation in
Mumbai and clarifies Islamic viewpoints
clearing misconceptions about Islam
using the Quran authentic Hadith and
other religious scriptures as a a basis
in conjunction with reason logic and
scientific
facts he has completed all of this study
and
preparation by the age now of 41 still
young but Sheik he is popular for his
critical analysis and convincing answers
to challenging questions posed by
audiences after his public talks in the
last 10 years Dr zacher has delivered
more than 1,000 public talks in the
United States of America Canada the
United Kingdom Saudi Arabia the United
Arab Emirates Kuwait Qatar Bahrain Oman
Australia New Zealand South Africa
batswana Malaysia Singapore Hong Kong
Thailand Guyana and South America and
many other countries in addition to
numerous public talks here in
India he has successfully participated
in several symposia and dialogues with
prominent personalities of other faiths
his public dialogue with Dr William
Campbell from the United States of
America on the topic the Quran the Bible
in the light of science was held in
Chicago the United States of America in
April of 2000 and was a resounding
success by the grace of
Allah Sheikh Ahmed didat the world
famous orator on Islam and comparative
religion who had called Dr zachik datat
Plus in
1994 presented a plaque in May of 2000
with the engraving awarded to Dr Zakir
Abdul Karim Nike for his achievement m
in the field of daah and the study of
comparative
religion son what you have done in four
years had taken me 40 years to
accomplish
alhamdulillah to end the quote of Ahmed
didat Dr zachar Nike appears regularly
on many International television
channels in more than 200 countries of
the world he has regularly invited
to TV and radio interviews more than
aund of his talks dialogues debates and
symposia are available on DVDs
vcds video cassettes audio cassettes and
he has authored several books on Islam
and comparative religion ladies and
gentlemen without further delay I would
like to welcome Dr Zakir Nike president
of the Islamic Research
Foundation alhamdulillah
my respected
elders and my dear brothers and sisters
I welcome all of you with Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of almighty
God be on all of
you the topic of this evening's talk of
mine
is the Quran and modern science
compatible or
incompatible the Glorious Quran is the
last and final revelation of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala of almighty God which
was revealed to the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him for any book to claim that it is the
word of God for any book to claim that
it is a revelation from Allah subhana wa
ta'ala it should stand and the test of
time
previously hundreds and thousands of
years back it was the age of Miracles
and
alhamdulillah the Glorious Quran is the
Miracle of
Miracles later on more than a thousand
years back it was the age of literature
and poetry when the Quran was revealed
and
alhamdulillah Muslims
and non-muslim Scholars
alike they claim the Glorious Quran to
be the best Arabic literature available
on the face of the
Earth and Allah subhana wa tala gives
the challenge of the Glorious Quran in
Surah Bak chapter number two verse
number 23 and 24 which
says and if you end doubt as what we
have revealed to our servant Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him from time to
time f
then produce a somewhat similar to
it and call forth your helpers and
Witnesses if there are any besides Allah
if your doubts are but
true and if you
cannot and of assurity you
cannot then fear the fire whose fuel is
men in Stones which is prepared for
those who reject
Faith here the Quran gives a challenge
they try and produce a Surah somewhat
similar to it and the shortest surra is
hardly three verses hardly few
words no one has done it so far and no
one inshah till eternity will ever be
able to do
it but today support a religious
scripture in a very poetic fashion says
that the world is
flat will a modern man believe in it but
natural no because today is not the age
of literature and poetry today is the
age of science and technology so let us
analyze today whether this glorious
Quran is compatible or incompatible to
modern science whether does it pass the
test of today
the test of modern
science according to Albert
Einstein the famous
physicist and the Nobel Prize winner he
said that science without religion is
lame and religion without science is
blind let me repeat it that Albert
Einstein the famous physicist and the
Nobel Prize winner said that science
without religion is lame
and religion without science is blind
let me remind you that the Glorious
Quran is not a book of signs s c i e n c
e but it is a book of signs s i g NS
it's a book of ayats and there are more
than 6,000 ayats 6,000 signs in the
Glorious Quran out of which more than a
thousand speak about SS
as far as my talk today is concerned I
will only be speaking about scientific
facts which have been established I will
not be speaking about scientific
theories and hypothesis which all of us
know very well that many a time these
theories and hypothesis they take
u-turns in the field of
astronomy in
1973 there were a couple of scientists
who got
the Nobel Prize and these couple of
scientists they described the creation
of the
universe and they called it the big
bang and they said that initially our
universe it was a primary
nebula then there was a big bang There
was a secondary
separation which gave rise to galaxies
the Stars the planets the Sun
the moon and the earth on which we live
this they called as the Big Bang the
Glorious
Quran mentions this in a nutshell 14400
years ago in Surah Amia chapter number
21 verse number 30 the Ayah I started my
talk with and it
says do not the unbeliever
see that the heavens and the Earth were
joined together and we clo Mund this
verse of the Glorious Quran speaks about
the Big Bang in a nutshell 1400 years
ago which science has discovered
recently hardly 30 years back 35 years
back the Glorious Quran says in Surah f
chapter number 41 verse number 11
moreover he comprehended in his design
the sky when it was
smoke and said to it and the Earth come
eat together either willingly or
unwillingly and they said we come in
willing
obedience Allah
says that he said to the sky when it was
smoke comeing together along with the
Earth willingly unwillingly and they
said we come together in willing
obedience today the scientist they tell
us that initially the celestial
matter of the universe it was in the
form of
gas and the Arabic word used in this
verse of Sur fah chapter 41 verse number
11 is
Duan dukhan does not merely mean gas it
specifically means smoke and today
scientists say that smoke is a more
closer and more scientific as compared
to gas because that time it was hot
imagine the Quran mentions 400 years ago
which we discovered recently that the
initial Celestial matter of the universe
it was in the form of
smoke previously the human beings we
thought
that the earth on which we live it is
flat it was in
1577 sanis Dr when he sailed around the
earth he proved that the Earth was
spherical Quran
mentions in Sur chapter number 31 verse
number 29 it is Allah subhana wa
tala who merges the night into day and
merges the day into
night it is Allah subhana wa ta'ala who
merges the night into the day and merges
the day into the night merging is a
gradual and slow process the night
slowly and gradually merges into the day
and the day slowly and gradually merges
into the night if the Earth was flat
there would have been a sudden change it
would have been a gradual process of
night mering through the day and day
merging into the
night Allah gives a similar message in
Surah AUM chapter number 39 verse number
5 it is Allah subhana wa ta'ala
who
overlaps the night unto the day and
overlaps the day unto the night the
Arabic word used here is kaara which
means to overlap a coil so the Quran
says it is Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala who
overlaps or coils the night unto the day
and collapse a coils the day unto the
night coiling the word kaara is used how
you coil a turbine unto your
head so this overlapping and coiling of
the night unto the day and the day unto
the night is only possible if the shape
of the Earth was spherical if it was
flat it was not
possible and Allah further says in Sur
nazat chapter number 79 verse number 30
we have made the Earth as an expands and
we have made the Earth ex
shaped means and then we made the Earth
ex shaped one of the meanings of D is an
expanse and the other meaning of the
Arabic word daha it is derived from the
Arabic word duya which means an egg and
we know today that the earth on which we
live is not completely round like a
ball it is geosphere in shape it is
flattened from the pole and is bulging
from the
center and the Arabic word
duya doesn't mean a normal egg it
specifically means the Egg of an ostrich
and if we analyze the shape of the Egg
of an ostrich it too is GEOS fical in
shape
Imagine The Glorious Quran mentions 1400
years ago that the shape of the earth is
geospheres not say spherical only
it specifically mentions like the Egg of
an
ostrich
previously the scientist they thought
that the light of the moon was its own
light but Quran says in Surah fan
chapter number 25 verse number
61 blessed is he that Allah subhana tala
who has made the constellation in the
sky and placed therein
Sun that is a
lamp having its own light and moon
having borrowed
light the Arabic word used for the sun
in the Quran it is Shams and its light
is always described as s
vahaj which means a torch having a light
of its own or a blazing lamp or a
shining Glory always the light of the
sun is disc described as wahaj s or
meaning a light of its
own the Arabic word for moon
isar and its light is described as M or
meaning borrowed light or a reflected
light there's not a single place in the
Quran where the light of the moon is
described as its own light and the
Arabic word for star is najam and its
light is described as Sak meaning the
light by the time it reaches the Earth
it loses its brightness like a piercing
brightness the bright light by the time
it reaches it consumes
itself and this
message that the sun has its own light
describing as vahaj s or and the moon
having borrowed light that is M or
reflection of n is mentioned in several
way in the Quran including Surah yunus
chapter number 10 verse number 5 as well
as Surah number 71 verse number 15 and
16 and the Quran says in Surah T chapter
number 86 verse number three that
what describing the star its light as s
that means it pierces it's a piercing
Darkness
previously the European
scientists they believed that the Earth
was the center of the solar system and
the universe and all the planets as well
as the moon and the sun it revolved
around the earth this was called as
geocentrism and this was believed since
the time of toomy in the 2 Century BC
till as late as 16th century until
Nicholas Copernicus in
15122 he prop founded the heliocentric
theory of the planetary motion and he
said it is the sun which is the center
of the solar system and all the planets
as well as the Earth it revolves around
the
Sun and later on a German Scientist by
the name of johanes Kepler in
169 he wrote in his book by the name
astronomia Novia that not only do the
planets and the Earth they revolve
around the Sun but they also rotate
about their own
axis and when I was in
school I passed my school
1982 about more than 25 years back there
I too
read that the planets and the Earth the
revolve on the sun and the planets and
the Earth they rotated about their own
axis and the whole solar system also in
the Galaxy it revolved including the Sun
but the sun did not rotate about its own
access in this context the sun was
stationary but when I read the verse of
the Quran inia chapter number 21 verse
number 33 which
says it is Allah who has created the
night and the
day the Sun and the Moon
each one traveling in orbit with its own
motion so the Quran says the Sun and the
Moon besides revolving they also rotate
about their own axis the Arabic word
used here is yes bahun derived from the
Arabic word
sabaha which describes the motion of a
moving body if I use this Arabic word
yaha for a person who's moving on the
floor it will not mean that he's rolling
it will mean he's either walking or
running if I use the same word for a
person in the water it will not mean
he's floating it will mean is swimming
similarly when Allah subhana wa ta'ala
uses the same word for a Celestial body
it does not mean that it is flying in
the air it means it is moving along with
its own
rotation it's rotating about its own
axis so Quran says the Sun and the Moon
besides revolving it also rotates about
its own axis and to
today science have discovered that even
the sun rotates since we can't see the
sun directly you get blinded if you see
directly if you have an equipment and
have the image of the sun on a tabletop
we find that there are spots in the sun
and it takes about 25 days for the spots
to complete one rotation indicating that
the sun takes approximately 25 days to
complete one
rotation imagine when I was in school I
was Tau the sun was station didn't rate
about own axis and the Quran mentioned 4
years ago that rotates and now
alhamdulillah most of the schools have
Incorporated that The Sun Also
rotates further we read in the Quran
it's mention the Quran in Surah
Yasin chapter number 36 verse number
14 it is not permitted for the sun to
overtake the moon nor the night to
outrip the
day the Moon and the Sun
each one traveling in Orit with its own
motion now the scientists say that the
orbit of the Sun and the Moon is
different so there's no question of the
Sun overtaking the
moon that's what the Quran says and
today the scientists they tell us that
the sun is moving in a direction in the
universe to a particular fixed Direction
which which is called as the solar
Apex in the constellation of Hercules
also known as
alphaa at a speed of 12
m/s and today the scientists they tell
us that the sunlight we have is due to a
chemical reaction which is taking place
since billions of
years and one day this chemical reaction
will cease and so will the light of the
sun cease to exist and so will the life
on this Earth cease to exist but the
scientists say it will take another few
billion
years Quran gives a similar message in
Surah yass chapter number 36 verse
number
38 that the sun is running its course
for a period determined to a place deter
mind the Arabic word used here is must
which has two meanings either it means
for a period
determined or it means to a place
determined and today science says that
the sun is moving to a particular spot
known as solar epic and it will exist
for a particular time period so both the
meanings of mustar to a place DET a mind
and for a period at mind according to
science is perfect imagine Quran
mentions this 400 years
ago when I was in school I had learned
that there are three types of matter
solid liquid and
gas and previously the scientists
believed that the space
outside the astronomical
systems in the Galaxy it was
vacuum lately the scientists have
discovered that there are bridges of
matter in the interstellar space it's
not vacuum and it is called as
plasma and they see this matter is in a
form of gous matter which has equal
number of positive ions as well as
electrons and the Quran mentions 400
years ago in Surah fan chapter number 25
verse number 59 it is Allah subhana wa
ta'ala who has created the heavens and
the Earth as well as things in between
it so Quran says there is matter in
between the heavens and the Earth which
today science they say that this plasma
can be considered as the fourth type of
matter today science also tells us that
the atmosphere of the earth it acts like
a filter and prevents the harmful
radiations from outer space to come onto
the surface of the Earth it prevents the
x-rays and the ultraviolet rays to reach
the surface of the Earth which is very
important for the sustainance of life if
this filter of the Earth's atmosphere
wasn't there then life would not exist
on the face of the Earth
the Quran says in Surah Amia chapter
number 21 verse number
32 that we
have made the sky as a protected
ceiling we have made the heavens the
Arabic word is samaat we have made the
heavens that is the sky as a canopy well
guarded today science has come to know
that this prod
ceiling without this life would have
ceased to existed on the face of the
Earth it was in
1925 a very famous
scientist by the name of edin Hubble and
a famous
astronomer he said that the galaxies are
receding that means the universe is
expanding the Quran mentioned 400 years
ago in Surat
chapter number 51 verse number 47 that
we have created the vastness of space
that aric word mus means vastness of the
expanding Universe the Quran mentions
400 years
ago that the universe is expanding which
we have come to know recently 80 years
back 90 years back and according to
Stephen Hawkins who's a very famous
scientist he writes in his book The
brief history of time he says that the
discovery of the expanding universe is
the greatest discovery of the century
which is mentioned in the Quran 14
centuries
before there may be
Skeptics or some
non-muslims who will say it is nothing
great that the Quran speaks about
astronomy since the Arabs were very well
advanced in the field of
astronomy I do agree with them that the
Arabs were advanced in the field of
astronomy but I'd like to remind them it
was centuries after the Quran was
revealed that the Arabs advanced in the
field of astronomy so it is from the
Quran that the Arabs learned about
astronomy and not the vice
versa and there were many things about
astronomy mission in the Quran which the
Arabs didn't speak about and which we
have come to
recently in the field of
physics several centuries
ago there was a theory which was called
as
atomism this was Advanced by the Greeks
especially Democrats who lived 2300
years before and according to this
theory of
atomism atom is the smallest part of
matter and this was also known to the
Arabs and the Arabic word for atam
in Arabic it's called a
zar and the Arabs also agreed the
smallest part of matter nothing can be
smaller than that and if you read the
Quran the Quran too speaks about the
atom now after science advanced in the
field of physics we agree that atom is
the smallest particle of matter having
the characteristics of the element but
an atom two can be
divided so does it mean that the Quran
is
outdated Quran says in Surah Sabah
chapter number 34 Verse number
three as well as in Surah yunus chapter
number 10 verse number
61 that when they say that is
unbelievers that the final a will never
come tell them it will surely come by
the
Lord in whose knowledge is the
Unseen and in whose record is the
smallest detail of an
atom
and there is nothing smaller or greater
than an atom which is not there without
being mentioned in his record clearly
that's propitious so the Quran says that
Allah has the knowledge of the Unseen
the minest detail of the atom is
mentioned and even things greater and
smaller than the atom is very clearly
mentioned in his is record so the Quran
mentioned 1400 years ago that there are
things smaller than the
atom which science has discovered
recently in the field of
hydrology we learn about the water cycle
in the school the water cycle what we
learn in the school was first described
in 1580 by Sir Bernard
palac and we learned in school that the
water evaporates from the ocean
it forms into clouds the clouds move
they rise they condense and the water
falls and flows back into the ocean and
the water cycle is
completed
previously in 7th Century
BC Tales of melus he said it was the
spray of the ocean which was picked up
by the
winds which fell into the interior as
rain people did not know how did the
rain fall so in 7th Century tales of B
is he said it was the spray of the ocean
which was picked up by the winds and
fell into the interior as rain people
did not know from where did the
underground water come and people
believed even in the time of plateau
that when the water
fell this water flowed by a secret
passage into the ocean called asterus
people did not know from where did the
underground water come so they thought
it was the pressure of the Winds on the
water
which forced the water into the
interior and even till as late as 17th
century people and great thinkers like
Des cartis believed in this Theory even
in 19th century people believed in the
Aristotle's theory that the water
evaporated from the earth and cooled in
Mountain caverns which fed the Springs
today we know that the underground water
is due to the seepage of the rain
water and Allah says in the
Quran in Surah zumar chapter number 39
verse number 21 see not thou that it is
Allah subhana wa ta'ala who sends on
water from the sky and causes it to soak
in the ground causes Springs into the
ground and then causes sewn field of
various colors to
grow Quran mentions in Sur Room chapter
number 30 verse number
24 it is Allah who send his own water
from the the
sky and then gives life to the Earth
after it is
dead the Quran says in Sur chapter
number 23 verse number 18 it is we who
send down water from the sky and we can
store it and we can even drain it
easily the Quran says in Surah chapter
number 15 verse number 22 that we cause
feating
winds that Arabic word used is Lai which
is the plural of Laha coming from
L which means to fate which means to
impregnate we cause feating winds we
cause winds to impregnate and then the
water falls from the sky and today we
know that science tells us that the
Poland is picked up by the winds and it
impregnates the clouds and the second
type is the clouds they join together
then there's light and waterfalls from
the sky a similar message of hydrology
and water cycle is mentioned in Surah n
chapter number 24 verse number
43 it is Allah who makes the clouds to
move gently and then causes them to join
then make them into a heap and then
water emerges from the
sky Quran says in Surah chapter number
30 verse number
48 that it is Allah subhana wa ta'ala
who makes the clouds to rise that makes
it into fragments and then water falls
from the sky the Quran speaks about the
water cycle in great
detail the Quran says in Surah tar
chapter number 86 verse number
11 which means by the capacity of the
Heavens to return
besides the sky or the heavens acting
like a protected ceiling besides
reflecting All The Unwanted dangerous
rays back into the space it also returns
back the water evaporation what the
water evaporate from the ocean the sky
it sends it back onto the
earth and the Quran says in Surah n
chapter number 24 vers 43 that we cause
water to fall from the sky from
mountains of
clouds and when we're traveling the
Aeroplane Aeroplane wasn't there 14
years back and when we look at the
clouds below we see it is like mountain
of wools
the clouds they appear as mountains
imagine Quran mentions that 14 years ago
Quran describes the water cycle in great
detail in several verses besides the
several verses I quoted there are many
other empty number of verses which speak
about the word cycle it's mentioned in
Surah chapter number 7 verse number 57
in Surah chapter number 13 verse number
17 in Surah fan chapter number 25 verse
number 48 and 49 in Surah f chapter 35
ver number 9 in Sur y chter number 36
ver number 34 it's mentioned in Sur
jashia chter number 45 ver number 5 in
Sur chapter number 50 verse number 9 and
10 it's mentioned Sur chapter number 56
verse number 67 to70 it's mentioned in
Sur M chapter number 16 verse number 30
you can go on only quoting the several
verses of the Quran which speak about
the water cycle you can only give a talk
on hydrology and water cycle in the
Quran
in the field of
geology and the geologist today they
tell us
that the radius of the earth on which we
live is approximately
3,750
mil and the deeper layers they're hot
and fluid it cannot sustain
life and as you keep on going
superficially it keeps on getting cooler
and The Superficial crust on which we
live it is
hardly less than 30 miles in
thickness and the geologist to tell us
there are high possibilities that this
superficial crust on which we live it
can shake and today the geologist tell
us they talk about the folding phenomena
which gives rise to mountain ranges and
because of this folding phenomena and
because of this mountain there is
stability on the earth the Quran
says in Surah chapter number 78 verse
number 6 and 7 we have made the Earth as
an
expand and the mountains as Stakes the
Arabic word aad means Stakes or tent
pegs like how we put a tent peg into the
ground we see only a small portion on
the top The major portion goes deep into
the
ground so the Quran says the mountains
are like tent pegs and today's science
tells us that the mountain has got Deep
Roots and the portion we see on the top
is only a small portion like the tip of
an iceberg The major portion of the
iceberg is in the water and only a small
portion is here on the top and science
tells us that the mountains
are put firmly on the earth and Quran
gives this mentioned 14 years
ago in Sur
nazat chapter number 17 9 verse number
32 as well as Gia chapter number
88 verse number 19 that we have placed
on the earth mountains standing
firm as far as the subject of geology is
concerned a book by the name the Earth
which is known as one of the best
textbooks in the field of geology and is
referred in most of the universities in
the subject and one of its authors his
name is Frank press
who was the president of the Academy of
Sciences of USA earlier and was also the
adviser to the ex president of USA jimy
cata and he writes in this book and he
draws the
mountain and shows that the mountain has
got deep roots in the shape of
veg veg shape and he shows that the
mountain that is seen above the surface
of the Earth is only a small portion The
major portion has got Deep Roots and and
he writes in this book that it is due to
the mountain which prevents the Earth
from shaking and this is exactly what is
mentioned in the Quran 14 years ago in
Surah Amia chapter number 21 verse
number 31 as well as Sur lman chapter
number 31 verse number 10 that we have
placed on the earth Mountain standing
firm lest it would shake with
you the Quran specifically mentions that
the function of the mountain is to
prevent the Earth from shaking which we
have come to
recently in the subject of
oceanology there's a verse in the
Quran in Surah fan chapter number 25
verse number 53 which say that it is
Allah subhah wa ta'ala who has let free
two bodies of flowing water one sweet
and palatable and the other salty and
bitter though they meet they do not mix
there is a barrier which is forbidden to
be
trespassed the same message is
repeated in surahman chapter number
55 verse number
19 that we have let free two bodies of
flowing water though they meet they do
not mix there is a barrier that is a
Barak which is forbidden to be
trespassed when the commentators of the
Quran
when they triy to understand this verse
all of us know very well and we knew it
earlier also that there are two types of
water sweet and salty but they could not
understand the verse of the Quran which
says that there are two types of water
sweet and salty though they meet they
did not mix there is a barrier which is
forbidden to be test passed there's a
bar the muin the commentator could not
understand what did it mean today after
have advanced we have come to know that
whenever one type of water flows into
the other type of water sweet water
flows into the salty water it loses its
constituents and gets homogenized into
the water it
flows this transitional homogenizing
area according to the Quran is called as
the Barak it is an unseen
barrier and this has been testified and
verified when this verse of the Quran
was show to prophet
who is a very famous marine
scientist and a professor in oceanology
in the University of Colorado in
USA and he said that what the Quran
mentions 4 years ago has been testified
by science recently and this phenomena
can be seen even with the naked eye at
the Cape Point the sou most tip of Cape
Town in South Africa
where one type of water flow into the
other type we even see that the colors
of both these Waters differ another good
example is in Egypt when River Nile
flows into the Mediterranean Sea and the
best example is a gulf stream it flows
for thousands of miles it starts from
the Gulf of
Mexico and goes to the east side of
North America travels upwards then goes
eastwards and travels to the west coast
of Europe it flows for thousands of
miles but yet the two waters are
distinct and if you're traveling in a
ship towards the extreme of the Gulf
Stream and pick up take a bucket of
water from the left side and a bucket of
water from the right side you'll find
that one is sweet and the other is salty
even the temperature between the two
they
differ imagine Quran speaks about this
phenomena 1400 years
ago in the subject of
biology the Quran says in Surah Ambia
chapter number 21 verse number
30 we have made from water every living
thing will you not then believe imagine
in the deserts of Arabia the Quran says
we have made from water every living
thing who could have believed in it
today after science advanc we have come
to know that every living creature has
got cells and the basic substance of
cell is cytoplasm which contains about
80% water and today science tells us
that every living creature contains
about 50 to 90%
water Quran mentioned in Surah n chapter
number 24 verse number 45 we have
created every living animal from water
the Quran says in Surah fan chapter
number 25 verse number 54 we have
created every human being from
water in the of botony previously we did
not know that even the plants have got
Sexes male and female we have come to
know about this recently recently me 100
years back 200 years back 300 years
back the Quran says in Surah chapter
number
20 verse number 53 it is Allah subhana
wa ta'ala who send on water from the
sky and with it brings various pairs of
plants each separate from the other the
Arabic word used each separate from the
other meaning male and female the Arabic
word used in the verse of the Quran is
awage meaning
spouses Sexes male or female so Quran
says that every kind of
plant has been made into Sexes male and
female and today science tells us that
all the plants they have got male and
female Sexes even the unisexual plant
they have distinct characteristic of
male and female the Quran says in Surah
chapter number 13 verse number three we
have created every kind of fruit in
peirs two and two even the fruits are
created in male and
female and today we know that the
Superior Plants the end stage is the
fruit before that stage is a flower
which has got stamin and ovules male and
female and Poland comes and fertilizes
and then we have the fruit having
distinct characteristic of male and
female even the parthenocarpic
fruits even they like banana figs
certain types of pineapple oranges they
have distinct characteristic these are
unfertilized fruits flowers from
unfertilized the fruits obtained even
they have distinct characteristics of
male and
female the Quran says
further in Surah
Yasin chapter number 36
verse number
36 it is Allah subhah wa ta'ala who has
created every animal in pairs and human
being in pairs and even things which you
know and don't know Allah says he has
created everything in pairs so besides
human beings animals plants even things
which we don't know today we know that
things like
electricity also have got positive and
negative the electrons and
protons and many things which we don't
know so Allah says he has created
everything in
pairs things we know as well as things
we don't
know in the field of
zoology the Quran says in Surah Anam
chapter number 6 verse number
38 we have made every animal that lives
on this Earth
and every creature which has wings and
flies in the air to live in communities
like the human beings today we have come
to know that the animals and birds like
the human beings they too live in
communities the Quran
says in Surah Nel chapter number 16
verse number 68 and
69 it is Allah subhana wa ta'ala who has
taught the bee to build its
cells in
Hills on trees and human
habitations and to eat of what the Earth
produces and to find the spacious path
of the Lord with great
skill it was recently just a few decades
earlier that a scientist by the name of
fwn
fresh he got the Nobel Prize for
describing the Behavior and the movement
of the
bee and what does the Quran mean by
saying it has taught the bee to build it
cells in Hills trees human habitations
eat of what the Earth produces and find
the spacious path of the Lord with great
skill today after science Advanced after
F fresh described the movement of the be
we have come to know that whenever a
bee finds a new Garden or a flower it
goes and tells its fellow B the exact
direction of that garden and flower so
that it could collect nectar by a
process known as the be dance